one of the reasons donald trump has
become so popular with many americans
lies in his gut level pro Americanism
Trump doesn't make blue-collar Americans
feel bad about themselves he tells them
they're not racist they're not sexist
Trump doesn't make those who earn feel
rotten he tells them he's earned too and
he's proud of it most of all though
Trump does not tear down law enforcement
that last fact was on full display on
Tuesday when the president-elect called
the family of San Antonio police officer
Benjamin Marconi who was murdered on
Sunday during a traffic stop Police
Chief William McManus said the uniform
was the target in the murder marconi
sunday and got on facebook and posted
quote just got off the phone with future
president Trump he sends his condolences
to our family trumps team has said
nothing about to call thus far this
isn't the first such call for Trump
post-election shortly after the election
Trump called the widow of murdered New
York Police Department sergeant Paul to
a xolo to offer condolences he said I'm
very sorry I cannot be here with you
today my thoughts and prayers are with
you and your family during this
difficult time this is classy stuff it's
also necessary President Obama's
sometimes called the families of slain
cops he routinely called the families of
black people shot by cops under disputed
circumstances at best when he spoke at
the funeral service for targeted and
murdered at Dallas police officers he
used the dais to rip police across the
country as suffering from implicit bias
and racism Americans rightly got the
impression Obama didn't care nearly as
much about targeted officers as he did
about his misguided crusade to slander
officers as the source of the anti-black
racism that is certainly not the message
from Trump Trump isn't standing by bad
police officers of course but he is
making it clear that he stands by police
officers across the country and that he
takes their life seriously that is a
hell of a change from the current
occupants of the Oval Office I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
alrighty so much to get to here today
but we begin by saying hello to our
sponsors at helix sleep so helix late
this is a great company and the way that
this works is you go to their website
helix sleep calm / been use the slash
spending at fifty dollars off your first
order helix sleep calm and the way that
they do this is they ask you questions
about your body type about your weight
that your height to ask questions about
whether you like a soft mattress or a
hard mattress you like it to be warm or
do you like it to be breathable and then
they send you the mattress in the mail
they send it to you in the mail and you
can try it out for a hundred nights for
free and if you don't like it you can
just send it right back a customized
mattress can cost you thousands and
thousands of dollars but he looks
mattress caught they cost you like a
fraction of that and in many cases under
a thousand dollars shipping is one
hundred percent free it comes in a box
and the way that it works is you unpack
the box and it automatically inflates
it's really cool and it is super
comfortable it is so comfortable that we
actually just got rid of a mattress that
we had very expensive mattress that we
had we actually put it in the other room
we got a new bed frame because we liked
our helix mattress so much we actually
just had that bed frame delivered
yesterday that's how much we like the
helix mattress its helix sleep calm /
ben helix sleep calm / men and yet fifty
dollars off your first order again it's
truly customized and you can even
customize it if there are two people on
the mattress you can customize it so
that each side is different which is
great and if you're Bill Clinton you can
make sure that one side is filled with
spikes that Hilary never sleeps in the
same bed I guess but in any case helix
sleep calm / Brown that's the place to
go to get this mattress and it is
terrific alrighty so lots to get to
today we begin with the Democrats so you
know the fact is that everybody's paying
attention to the Trump transition and
we'll get to that in a little while
there's been some more good Trump bad
Trump with regard to the the pics that
he's making for his cabinet dr. ben
Carson has been picked which is error
but then also just picked a woman in
Betsy DeVos for the for the head of set
for the Secretary of Education which is
a great pic he's been stomping all over
the grave of Kelly I out which is also
kind of work but he's made apparently
nikki Haley the UN Ambassador which is a
great pic so we'll talk about all of
those and what they mean and why this is
happening but first we need to talk
about the Democrats because the
Democrats are totally falling apart they
are utterly falling apart Elijah
Cummings is a Democrat I
leave that Elijah Cummings is from from
Alabama sorry Marilyn my bad so Elijah
Cummings is from Maryland and and he is
basically the Democrats are struggling
for identity they're struggling for
identity and that means that they have
to fall back on the tried and true
strategies those strategies include of
course saying the black people are going
to be victimized by white Republicans
and saying the gay people will be
victimized by Trump they have to play
identity politics there's been a lot of
talk in the aftermath of Trump winning
about Democrats dumping identity
politics at the door stop alienating
white folks by claiming they're all
racists stop alienating men by claiming
they're all sexist stop alienating rich
people by saying that they're all greedy
you actually start pitching your
policies logic Cummings however he says
not we can't do that there's no way I
think that we I think we need to know I
don't necessarily agree I think we need
to deal with economics I think economics
is very important but I think that we
need to still pay attention to so many
people who have been left out of the
system in one way or another just like
what I just talked about voting rights
of certain segments of our population I
think we can do do both but we've got to
concentrate one economics because a lot
of people are suffering and
african-americans and Hispanics are
suffering probably more than other parts
of our communities and so that would be
my answer there okay so he says that we
need to double down on the identity
politics of course he thinks they need
to double down on the identity politics
the Democrats have created this new
Obama coalition that is largely based on
pressing forward identity politics and
that of course has driven a sort of
Kwazii identity politics from the right
that is not my favorite thing but
Cummings is wrong obviously the way the
Democrats if they actually wanted to win
could win is by abandoning those
identity politics or maybe they're so
far down that road there's no way to do
it maybe they're afraid that if they
have bands and identity politics may be
more black people will vote Republican
because they won't feel pressured to
vote Democrat because those Republicans
are evil racist so they keep doubling
down on this one of the ways they're
doubling down on this is the push for
keith Ellison Muslim congressperson from
Minnesota the reason s a Muslim
congressperson is because there are only
two Muslims in the United States
Congress i believe the other one is
Andre Carson and
and Alison of course was the first I
think Muslim congressperson in in the
Congress and so he's gotten major play
politically over that he's being talked
about very seriously for head of the
Democratic National Committee there's a
problem there and that is that is that
keith ellison is a radical radical
anti-semite in his he's radically
anti-israel he's associated with the
Nation of Islam and the Democrats don't
know what to do they're endorsing
Ellison because they're doubling down on
the identity politics so here's
Elizabeth Warren the senator from
Massachusetts and the supposed God queen
of the love the hardcore left talking
about why keith Ellison would be a
terrific choice I talked with
Congressman Ellison I really really like
Keith and I think he's terrific and I
think he would make a terrific DNC chair
I just recently heard that Howard Dean I
mean literally just a few minutes ago
heard that Howard Dean maybe says I'm n
talk to him fine I'd like to hear what
his vision is uh but I want lots of
Democrats in engaged and ready to go and
she is so irritating and she's also
wrong on this I know professor she was
Professor warm when i was at harvard law
school she was irritating then she's
become twice as irritating now with her
foes sincerity but just a little bit of
background about keith ellison so the
person she just praises a terrific
choice for the DNZ this is tape of keith
ellison in 2007 when he was asked about
911 here's here's this herb legs tape
you never have all this discrimination
his religious minorities at but for 911
and again you had it but you didn't ever
to the degree that we have it down all 9
11 is this is this juggernaut event in
American history and it allows it's
almost like you know the right stock
fire kind of reminds me of that said I
know what I'm talking about do benefit
11 new benefited from that 11 new
benefited from 911 well I mean you know
you and I don't know bush but the thing
is is that you know after the right stop
was burned they blamed the communist for
it and input on the leader of that
country in a position where he could
basically have authority to do whatever
you want okay so he compared the 911 if
you missed it to the Reichstag fire
which was a faked fire by the Nazis in
order to loud Hitler to consolidate his
power so he's actually I mean this is
this is a far-left radical Islamist lie
that has been pushed by by people from
from those contingents and there's keith
ellison by the way you hear the guy in
the audience saying the Jews benefited
from 9-11 and Ellison basically going
yeah maybe I mean this is the guy
they're talking about for head of the
DNC but that's not the only thing that
we know about keith Ellison Joel Mowbray
my friend who writes / Daily Caller he
wrote the man poised to head the
Democratic Party was a spokesman for the
Nation of Islam well into his 30s the
nation of islam is a radically
anti-semetic group led by Lewis
Farrakhan he publicly spewed
anti-semitism and later in life as a
congressional candidate knowingly
accepted fifty thousand dollars in
campaign contributions given and raised
by Islamic radicals who openly supported
Islamic terrorism and were leaders of
front group for Hamas and the Muslim
Brotherhood by the way the periods are
in which Ellison defended the Nation of
Islam the spokespeople were openly
jew-hating in 1995 that guy is on tape
keith Ellison he led a rally featuring a
guy named Holly to Abdullah Mohammed was
a nation of islam member Mohammed got up
and said quote if words were swords the
chests of Jews gays and whites would be
pierced Ellison also defended Louis
Farrakhan as quote not a racist not an
anti-semite farah khan has called Jews
Devils okay and in in that's not where
it stops by the way here is tape of
representative Ellison saying that he
voted against funding for irons on this
in the middle of a war in which Israel
is being hit by rockets he voted against
funding Israel's capacity to defend
itself points for John Kerry's run
around trying to achieve one I think is
exactly i ask you on that point you
always supported iron dome which is the
Messiah assistant but you go just voted
against more money for it why because a
ceasefire is what we should prioritize
now
what we cease fire protects civilians on
both sides it doesn't just say we're
only concerned about people on one side
I am cuz I've been a store wrote I've
stood with those people talk about those
Rockets in that indiscriminate rocket
fire and I've also been the Gaza three
times since 2009 and I think those
people are absolutely devastated wigging
up he sees fire now okay so the way that
he wants to cease fire is by removing
Israel's protection from indiscriminate
rocket attack that's keith ellison the
guy they're talking about for head of
the DNC just a couple of months ago he
wrote in The Washington Post quotas I've
talked with ordinary Gosselin's I have
not encountered anyone representing
Hamas the Gaza Strip is literally run by
the terrorist group Hamas Ellison openly
associates with the campaign to end the
Israeli occupation which is a virulent
lee anti-israel interest group that
labels Democrats like Chuck Schumer
Chuck Schumer is Democrat right and
Israel ferster Democrats by the way will
not talk about this he won't talk about
this he's been avoiding interviews for
literally weeks now Josh crash our
National Journal he tweeted this morning
Dems really don't want to talk about
Ellison's record on Israel no comments
at one Schumer a lie many stories
avoiding elephant in the room right
meanwhile the the anti-defamation league
which has done yeoman's work on
criticizing the all right they have
nothing to say about keith Ellison and
the fact that the leader of the DNC
maybe this guy who is openly associated
with anti-semites and in fact has
engaged in openly anti-semitic behavior
here was the statement from Jonathan
Greenblatt Greenblatt by the way I've
met him nice guy but Jonathan Greenblatt
was a was an Obama staffer okay and
here's what here's the statement from
the ADL quote we spoke with the
leadership in the Jewish community in
Minnesota who confirmed what a dl and
other national organization
organizations have seen that keith
ellison is a man of good character we
have seen him through his work in
congress as an important ally in the
fight against anti-semitism and for
civil rights nonsense nonsense nonsense
he has been on the record in support of
Israel hahahaha and supports a two-state
solution however the congressman has
also made statements and taken positions
especially regarding the
israeli-palestinian conflict and on the
jcpoa that would be the Iranian
agreement on which we strongly differ
and that concern us we hope that
candidates for this post will make clear
where they stand on these issues and
that the Democratic National Committee
will make a choice that affirms
long-standing bipartisan consensus to a
strong us Israel
relationship in addition we want to make
clear to those who disagree with
congressman Allison that in doing so
there's no room for innuendo or slander
because of his race or faith it's not
about his race or faith it has
everything to do with his views and the
views that he is openly espoused right
but again left-wing Jews are not
criticizing Ellison they're criticizing
the alright only and you got a bunch of
people in the media who are completely
ignoring the fact that Bernie Sanders
and Elizabeth Warren and the entire left
wing of the Democratic Party are
supporting for the head of the DNC a guy
who's interested in doubling down on
identity politics and who also has spent
his entire adult life associating with
the worst kinds of vile anti-semitism
you can imagine but again these people
are all over steve benen which is okay
but they are completely leaving alone
keith Ellison and I do want to point out
here that there's a mistake that people
on both sides seem to make and that is
they play the double standard game they
say well you know they're focusing on
banner but they're not focusing on
Ellison therefore we shouldn't focus on
bandit no that's not the proper
conclusion the proper conclusion is you
should focus on bandhan and you should
focus on Ellison by the way Ellison is a
significantly more dangerous character
then Bannon is with regard to his views
ban is just a cynical opportunist who's
willing to use the alt right to get
where he wants to go Ellison is somebody
who actually believes all these things
right means somebody who spent his time
in the night he's calling himself Keith
X Ellison because he was an actual
member of the Nation of Islam and the
media have nothing to say about it the
point of the double standard argument
should be to restore the standard not to
tear it down the point of saying why
aren't you covering X when you're
covering why is not to say you shouldn't
cover why it's saying you should cover
all of it but again people tend not to
buy into that because everybody's a
partisan unfortunately now the Democrats
are falling apart over this stuff
because a lot of them are saying like
congressman Tim Ryan from Ohio why are
we doubling down on the identity
politics that just lost us the selection
and are leading to ever increasing
numbers of white folks in the rural
areas running away from the Democratic
Party and running instead toward the
Republicans and then you've got people
saying we got to double down on the gal
that brung us we're building this new
coalition the demographics favor us we
got to double down on the identity
politics the Democrats are tearing
themselves apart and they're becoming in
the process a regional party a party
that only exists in California and New
York and some major cities around the
country but nowhere in the rural areas
the entire middle of the country is
basically now red with
exception of Illinois and that's an
amazing thing and look at the map it's
pretty incredible but the Democrats do
have one hope and that hope is that
Donald Trump is a complete crap show
that's that's their hope here and Elijah
Cummings basically says that he says you
know while he's trying to figure out
what the strategy ought to be he's
saying while Trump's business is a
minefield for conflicts the president
can't have a conflict of interest is
that problematic in your view it is
problematic because clearly I don't
think mr. Trump realizes how significant
the the minefield is in this area keep
in mind wolf that during the campaign he
said one of his top priorities would be
to bring honesty to government he also
talked about draining the swamp and use
a lot of terms basically saying that he
was going to clean up government and he
was going to make sure that they would
be transparency when you have your doing
in so many with so many businesses in so
many countries it's basically a
minefield for conflicts and to say that
because you are the president that the
law does not apply to you it's not so
much just the law it is the appearance
of conflict okay so Cummings here is
basically saying we're banking on Trump
to blow this thing and if you're rooting
for Trump to actually be a successful
president to do good things particularly
conservatives if you're betting on him
to do good things you want him to stop
doing the stuff where he's associating
his business interests the only hope for
the Democrats is that Trump disgraces
himself and then they come back because
2018 the map looks terrible for
Democrats in the Senate it looks awful
for them they have a bunch of vulnerable
seats in red areas they're going to lose
a lot of senators they're gonna lose six
to eight senators in 2018 it's a
disaster area for them unless Trump
blows this almost Trump blows this you
have to be rooting instead for Trump to
actually get his act together and that
means holding him to the same standards
which you'd hold Hillary Clinton if you
were able to portray rightly Hillary
Clinton is a corrupted Kratt you do not
get to turn around and then proclaim
that Trump is clean as the driven snow
pure as the driven snow when he's
intermingling his business
assets and his presidency and even the
appearance of that is something that
should be shunned and there's an article
today we mentioned it a couple of days
ago there's talk that Trump had gotten
on a call with the President of
Argentina and the President of Argentina
had called to congratulate him and Trump
had brought up his permit for Trump
Tower in Argentina and both sides denied
it today that permit went through today
that permit went through so if nothing
was said that's just a giant coincidence
this kind of stuff does not look good
and it's going to it's going to allow
Democrats to drag Trump through the mud
rightly or wrongly because where there
is smoke there usually is fire now
before we go any further I got us got a
signal to our our other advertiser's DST
l.d.d stld calm is distilled calm these
folks make jeans and the jeans are
terrific so instead of buying $200 jeans
or a hundred dollar jeans and distilled
you can get these jeans for like 65
bucks a pair and they have many
different types of jeans the material is
really is really friendly to your to
your skin I will say it is they fit
really well and again you can get two
pairs of jeans for the same price that
you get one someplace else they're
really terrific they don't waste
material they are environmentally
friendly for those who care about that
sort of thing it's dstl decom and if you
use / been dstl decom / been you get ten
dollars off right now they also have a
new line of fall jackets as well that
you can check out they don't work with
middlemen which is why they can do this
so cheaply this is high-end denim it's
it's really good stuff I own a pair and
I'm buying another pair dstl decom /
been for ten dollars off your first
order okay so now on to what Trump is
actually what Trump is actually doing so
he's made a bunch of cabinet pics in the
last 24 hours one of them makes I think
a whole world of sense for him
politically it doesn't necessarily make
sense in terms of the job but it makes a
lot of sense politically and that is the
choice of nikki Haley for you an
ambassador so the governor of South
Carolina Trump has now picked her for un
ambassador and she is going to she's
going to accept this makes sense for a
number of reasons first of all does she
have any foreign policy experience not
not really mm-hmm you know at the UN
your entire job basically consists of
just yelling at other useless people at
the UN so that doesn't necessarily
require anybody with great foreign
policy chops as governor of South
Carolina she did stand strong with
Israel against the boycott
sanctions movement that is worth noting
but the real reason that Trump appointed
her is pretty obvious one it gets rid of
a potential rival if he does a bad job
and someone's going to primary him it
could be somebody like nikki Haley too
it gets rid of these charges of racism
people have been saying his cabinet is
filled with white men nikki Haley is a
woman of Indian descent as Ann Coulter
has made eminently clear and and Donald
and Donald Trump is attempting to sort
of get past the alt right thing by
appointing a woman of the Indian descent
third it actually has the effect of
elevating Trump allies so even though
nikki Haley was not a strong Trump ally
she critiqued Trump a lot during the
campaign criticized him a lot the person
who is the lieutenant governor of South
Carolina will now become the governor's
a guy named Henry McMaster McMaster was
a huge Trump supporter throughout the
primaries endorsed him as early as
January even before the first primaries
were held in Iowa finally it makes Trump
look a little bit more broad-minded than
he probably is because it looks like
he's bringing someone in who disagrees
with him about foreign policy again the
reason I say that that's exaggerated is
because you an ambassador doesn't really
have much of a say if he picks Mitt
Romney for Secretary of State then you
start to change her calculus about the
kind of administration he's going to run
maybe he's going to bring in some people
who disagrees that's one of his cabinet
pics you want to hear me talk about the
rest of his cabinet pics however you'll
have to go over to daily wire.com right
now and become a subscriber eight
dollars a month will get you your
subscription you can become part of the
mailbag today we're going to do a live
mail bag in just about 20 minutes here
i'm ben shapiro show we usually do it on
thursdays tomorrow's thanksgiving if
you're an annual subscriber then you get
a free copy of my novel sign by me and
you also get the ads removed and from
the website and all the rest of it you
get andrew clements show as well you get
that live you get to be part of his
mailbag and we're adding new goodies all
the time go to daily wire calm right now
to become a subscriber and we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you